foreign
[Music]
has emotional infidelity and if she's
abusive or neglectful or if I'm just
being too sensitive and needy because
that's basically what she's told me
[Music]
what up what up this is John the Dr John
deloney show show where we talk about
your mental health your emotional health
your marriage dating your kids whatever
you got going on in your life I'm here
to walk alongside you and we're going to
figure out what's the next right step to
take right what's the next right
decision
you need to move you need to step out
you need to go see somebody I'm here to
walk alongside you we're going to figure
it out if you want to be on the show we
can really talk about anything anything
that's going on in your life give me a
call at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 leave a message let us
know what's going on and how we can get
in touch with you and Jenna will give
you a call back or go to John
deloney.com ask ask ask
and listen I got two asks for you ask
number one don't forget building a
non-anxious life here it is I'm holding
the real copy here they're in the
they're in the studio now
um that is still out for pre-sale go to
John deloney.com it's 20 bucks and we're
gonna send you a whole bunch of cool
stuff with it
um you can download a talk I just gave
to a couple thousand people right away
right when you pre-order it but go check
it out John deloney.com is 20 bucks and
here's the other thing uh if you don't
got 20 bucks to spare totally get it
times your bananas student loans are due
all I get it I get it I feel just
subscribe hit hit up give us a five star
review if you'll just hit the like
button or whatever however you're
consuming this thing just tell the
machine you like it and it helps kick
the show up into the algorithms the show
moved into the top five which is just I
can't even wrap my head around that I'm
so grateful for all of y'all who just
hang out with us all the time
um your time is the most precious thing
you got and you share one two three
hours with us a week I'm so so blown
away by all that thank you for for being
with us and thank you for all the notes
that people are sending letters direct
messages just letting us know how the
show is impacting your life
and I just want to say this
um everyone says thank you thank you
thank you and I'm grateful for that but
listen I'm just a clown on a podcast I'm
just a guy who lives in a neighborhood
uh a very very rural neighborhood but
just a guy lives in the neighborhood
trying to raise my kids and be as good a
husband as I can be and
um I got a long way to go on both of
those fronts
you're the you're the men and women who
are changing your lives you're doing the
hard work
you're putting up boundaries you're
telling your husband and wife that
you're that you're worried about your
marriage you're you're moving out you're
filing for you're doing the hard things
you're changing generational family
trauma you're doing the hard work
so I'm so grateful that you're with us
keep doing the hard things because man
heading into those storms that's where
the healing is so grateful for you let's
go out to my hometown H-Town gostros and
talk to the Mighty Joe what's up Joe
hi Dr John what a pleasure to speak with
you it's a pleasure to speak with you
man hey Art
our our boys gonna pull it out or what
oh I believe so I think they're gonna
make one last trade here at the end and
I think we're gonna pull it over the top
ah dude that's my Joe I'm in man I'm in
all right so what's up
yeah man I've I've listened to countless
hours of your show and uh man you've
helped me you've helped me a ton and so
I just want to say thank you for that
first off
um my question is
um
you've talked about emotional infidelity
and you talked about emotional abuse
and I'm I'm wanting to understand if if
my wife is emotionally
um it has emotional infidelity and if
she's abusive or neglectful or if I'm
just um being too sensitive and needy
because that's basically what she's told
me
who
there's a lot of layers here already man
so so let me know what's going on
yeah so the back story
um you know I met my wife
um through
um actually her cousin uh we worked
together uh she introduced me to my wife
now and
um you know everything was great in the
beginning I thought she was a wonderful
person
um she was a wonderful person and she
was a I thought she had a wonderful
heart she's a teacher just like your
wife is
um and she really really loved kids and
that was one of her big things that she
really really wanted to have kids so we
got married and
um we immediately tried to have kids
because I knew how important that was to
her and I wanted to have kids too and
you know I never you know thought I was
going to be ready and I don't think you
ever already you just had to kind of
jump into it so
um we had kids right away I mean we when
we tried to have kids it happened very
very quickly
um but but quickly after we have kid had
kids
um
the our sex life just fell apart
um I combined it in her you know that I
needed the intimacy and
um you know that I I felt like she was
really distant and
she basically just told me you know I'm
too tired
um I don't have time for it or there's
always an excuse
um
we we went to counseling for a bit
and
um
during the counseling sessions it came
up
and then
for whatever reason she basically just
told the counselor that she didn't want
to continue anymore
um so it stopped
um it's gone from so wait hold on so
when you brought up
when you're talking about what are the
challenges in your relationship and you
brought up the lack of sexual intimacy
um y'all aren't sleeping together you're
not in in usually these conversations
are not just about doing it they're also
about like
you don't hold my hand you you leave the
room when I walk in like there's not
that Gentle Touch on my shoulder like so
there's a whole picture here when you
brought that up right she just said this
conversation's over I'm out
I mean it wasn't that quickly but it was
it was very relatively quickly I mean it
was brought up towards the end of one
one session and then the beginning of
another session she said she just didn't
want to continue anymore and
um another backstory with her what she's
told me about her past is she's been
married was married previously and she's
confided to me that her ex-husband was
physically abusive
um not it was like a one one time
occurrence but he was
um and you know I've always thought okay
well that has something to do with it
um and I think the counselor was trying
to see if there was some back history
there so that might be another reason
why she tried to shut it down
um but the thing about this what she
told me though about her past it's
been a little confusing over the years
is you know I was very sympathetic of
what she told me and you know it broke
my heart
um but I've come to find out over the
years that she's never told anybody
about it nobody only me and she didn't
want anybody else to know about it so I
hate this I don't want to say that I
don't believe her but
initially you know I believed 100 and
then as time has gone on
I'm starting to question
whether or not
the story was 100 true or not sure that
makes sense yeah tell me about emotional
infidelity
I mean she
she's very passive aggressive
um
um I've written I've tried multiple
different Avenues to try to get through
to her on how I feel you know I've done
the direct approach where I sit her down
and talk to her
um I've written her letters
I've written her poems
um and
it was almost
kind of like well this is I mean this is
ridiculous like you're she has told me
directly that I'm needy and too
sensitive basically what she's told me
and
she's very dismissive also of things
that are important to me yeah
um like I'll give you an example of
something small but it came up the other
day
I'm I'm really big on communication and
we obviously have a horrible Community
um communication sorry if horrible
Communication in our marriage and one of
the things that I've asked her to do is
look if any if she's gonna have any
friends or family come over
you know just let me know so I know in
advance they're coming
and she doesn't she hardly ever does it
and the other day someone just popped up
and I had no idea where they were coming
and I asked her I said why you know why
didn't you tell me they were coming
because I don't need to tell you that
hmm
so
um just just for technicality emotional
infidelity the way I would classify that
is somebody that has feelings for
somebody else
they haven't slept with them they're not
holding hands they're not going on dates
but somebody who has chosen to confide
in somebody that's not their person
they're married to so super super common
sneaks up on you
um and it can definitely be worked
through but it definitely is a thing
right that doesn't sound like what's
going on here
what sounds like what's going on here
and and I I always want to enter into
these spaces very carefully okay because
um I just want to tell for the larger
the the people listening
one of the things you never ever want to
do when somebody confides in you like
you're doing right now what you're
saying Joe is hard to say right you're
saying things out loud you're being
pretty vulnerable with me and I'm really
grateful for it that's hard for a dude
to say
hey man I'm like pouring myself out to
her and she just keeps shutting me down
it's my wife is my mother of my kids
right that's hard to say out loud right
and my guess is you don't tell a whole
bunch of people that
um but one of the Cardinal rules when
somebody opens up to you is to never bad
mouth their spouse because they might
get back together and then they're going
to remember what you when you're like
yeah she sucks then they y'all reconcile
you're always gonna know like that dude
said my wife sucks you know what I mean
so I always want to tread carefully here
but I also want to be really honest and
we have a a contracted time to talk so
can I just be direct straight ahead is
that cool
sure
um
yeah you're dealing with somebody I'm
not going to diagnose her over the phone
obviously but you're dealing with
somebody who doesn't give a crap about
you
and I I need you to hear me say this
directly you're not crazy
in fact
um given what you've told me now I know
there's always two sides to every story
right and I've had these conversations
where I talked to a dude like this and I
talk to her and she's like oh yeah let
me fill you in and it's like okay that
makes sense
um
but I don't get that sense from you man
I sounds like a guy who loves his wife
and is doing everything he can to
connect with her
from the direct approach the indirect
approach the I'm going to help around
the house approach to the hey you wanna
dream together approach to hear some
poetry approach it's not like you're
doing everything you can man and you're
consuming stuff like this show you're
trying to figure out what is it about me
and I want you to hear me say I don't
think it's you man
I don't think it's you and let me tell
you why that's hard to say
because now you're left with this
terrifying well now what
right because it's not doesn't sound
like there's something you can just go
fix
um
I'm gonna say Something's Gonna sound
really callous
and I'm saying this as somebody who's
been through my own hell and back okay
and also has worked with a whole bunch
of people
trauma is very very real I wrote a whole
book about it
and it Cascades through a person's
entire life and through their family
tree if they don't deal with it
and
it's not an excuse to shut your life
down
and so we do not choose the trauma that
happens to us we don't choose the abuse
the marginalization we don't choose
being born in the wrong neighborhood the
wrong color all those things we don't
choose that stuff we do choose what
comes next
and so it sounds like somewhere along
the way either hell visited your wife
either before she was your wife when she
was a little kid whatever
or like you said now I'm starting to
even doubt if that's even true here's
the deal it honestly doesn't matter what
matters is is She gonna look at the
person she committed her life to and say
I hear you
I may not be able to sleep with you
three times a week right now I get that
but I also understand that I can't go
through my whole life not touching my
husband
I'm gonna go do the work I need to do to
be well
I'm gonna go see a counselor I'm gonna
go sit with a mentor I'm gonna go figure
out why does my body pull away when the
man I love leans in the father of my
kids leans in
right and so that's her work to do and
you can't do it and it sounds like what
you're saying man she doesn't have any
interest at all in doing it
no it doesn't I mean everything that's
important to me just she shuts down I
mean I go to church every every Sunday
with my boys and my dad I've asked her
on multiple occasions you know to come
that I thought was very important and
she just gives me excuses why she
doesn't want to go and I'll give you a
great example you know of one of the
reasons why I wrote wrote In
so recently I had a car accident
um that wasn't that someone cut me off
and and it totaled my truck and I wasn't
hurt you know until I had to go to the
hospital but I was pretty shaken up and
I had pretty bad whiplash and when I you
know called her about the accident she
instead of coming to the accident she
said do I need to come
and so of course I was like no you're
fine just stay
and then
uh when she got home that evening
you know I told her I said hey you know
I could really use
some intimacy you know my you know my
life kind of flashed before my eyes and
you know I really could use you know you
to help me rub my shoulders and help
help me you know fulfill the better and
her exact words were I'm not doing that
because I might make your condition
worse
so that's what kind of like set me over
the top to to write it right in can I
Can I Be a Jerk for a second
sure I just want to paint you an
opposite picture here my wife and I buy
a thousand miles are not perfect okay
like I don't want anyone to at all at
all to think that
right
um last year when I was doing
um my Wim Hof breathing exercises in my
car doing 85 miles an hour down the
highway
um and I passed out and I totaled my car
I was okay I actually drove the car it
went I drove it in and parked it at the
office and had it towed out of here
um but I got here
and I called my wife and I said hey I
totaled the car I'm okay
just wanted to let you know I'm safe if
somebody saw me on the side of the road
or whatever I want you to know I'm okay
and it was about 35 or 45 minutes later
and we lived 30 minutes from here my
wife showed up here
right and she had tears in her eyes and
she said I just need to see you
and she came and gave me a hug and like
but I need you to know that's the other
side
I tell you all that to tell you it's not
a fantasy you're not a needy whiny guy
you're not crazy
but I also want to tell you this
you have to get out of her head and stop
playing the what if I just do this what
if I just do this game
right you have to shift into what I'm
going to call a whole other mode
and it's terrifying dude
you have to ask yourself
this is who she is and this is who she
is choosing to be
when it comes to spiritual matters when
it comes to sexuality when it comes to
connectivity and if it hasn't already
it's gonna show up with parenting
decisions and choices
okay so let me say this as clearly as I
can she does not care about you
and I hate saying that
but you you feel that
you have to feel it so you'd have to ask
yourself what am I going to do next
and I can't give you that answer that
might be all right cool unless this is
the life I chose this is the person I
chose I'm gonna settle in here
um this might be you sitting down with a
counselor and begin saying what does
life look like not with her
um this might look like sitting down
with her and saying okay I've reached
I've reached the line here
um and I want to say this when it comes
to infidelity um you may have heard me
say this and so I'll I'll make sure I
clarify myself here
um we talk about infidelity a lot as
like did you have sex with somebody did
you text somebody did you kiss somebody
I think infidelity is a whole is an
infinitely bigger picture
right it's about withholding it's about
denial it's about I'm gonna be about my
life over your life
I'm gonna be about my wants and my needs
and I don't care about the the Covenant
I made with you that you're going to be
about we're going to be about doing life
together
and so
um I take a much wider angle when it
comes to infidelity because a lot of
people are just flat out terrible
Marriage Partners they're selfish
they're narcissistic they're jerks
they're they're quasi not physically but
they're quasi-abusive they're just awful
but then they say I didn't sleep with
anybody
yeah dude but you violated the Covenant
of this marriage because when you get
married you say you before me
and she says
you before me and you spend the rest of
your life
in service to one another
and y'all are in service to building
something completely new man and here's
the thing I hate this for you dude and
if you were here I'd give you a hug man
because I I know what I'm telling you is
like a sack of bricks on your shoulder
because you felt it and you felt it and
you felt it but
you gotta ask yourself what do I do next
what I do next
and I'm gonna recommend you get with
somebody probably a professional or a
minister in your community or it sounds
like your old man and you were pretty
close I would sit down with somebody and
have get some reflection and you can go
into a lot more detail with this person
foreign
I'm sorry
I'm sorry that your wife is
um choosing
to
kick dirt in your face
choosing to not connect choosing to
leave you out in the cold
I'm so sorry man and if your wife has a
rebuttal to this if she watches this and
she's like oh you need to know the other
half I'd love her to call in man I'd
love for the other side of the story but
this is the one I got and quite honestly
it breaks my heart but this is not an
uncommon story
for somebody gets married has kids and
they've they're done with him now I can
have my life the one that I wanted with
what I wanted I'm I'm through with this
and I hate that for everybody hate that
for the kids I hate that for for both
both the the both the husband the wife I
hate it for everybody
head for everybody
thanks for the call my brother I wish I
had some better news or something like
oh yeah just try this
sounds like you've gone to the ends of
the Earth man
you're gonna have to live in that season
of what do I do now and when you make
that decision of what I'm gonna do now
you got to be at peace with it
you got to be at peace with
because living in that gray space man
will kill you
sit with somebody else who tries who you
trust who can reflect back with you
you all make a path for moving forward
man call anytime I can help hang on the
line I'm gonna send you a copy of on
your past change your future man just
free of charge it's a book for you to
read it's about what to do when
everything falls apart and how to pick
up the pieces and take A New Path we'll
be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes and life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right hey we're back um Kelly's out
and Jenna's producing the show today so
Joe's gonna tell you this
um
because you were out and about when this
happened Joe you may have been in there
too
so I was sitting there scrolling through
Instagram the other day and the team
over here posted that clip of when Dave
and Rachel Dave Ramsey and Rachel were
on the air and a woman called in and
asked about selling her house
and it turned out there was a life or
death abuse situation and a little
infant kid in real time happening on the
air
and while this was going on I had no
idea I'm back in my office and I come
out to use the restroom which is like
right by the studio and then I stuck my
head in just to be an idiot like I
always am like hey everybody and Kelly
was running the phones and she looked at
me and said get in here now and she took
off her headset and just handed it to me
I didn't know what was going on and I
talked to this woman and we were on the
phone for about an hour and there was
there was a a an extended period of time
when I thought I was going to hear
somebody get murdered in real time and
unfortunately I've had experience in
those situations but I've never had it
where I'm not there and this was just on
the phone it was a terrifying
transaction of walking this woman
through she was amazing this man had her
kid it was a whole thing we called the
police got the police there it was
amazing and then ended up working with
her for months afterwards and Dave paid
for I mean it's been amazing how the
company supported all that was all it
was great I tell you that to tell you
this I was there I was there I worked
through that situation and I went home
and I mean it was just kind of par for
the course
and then John uh I'll call him John 3.0
John has been to a lot of counseling in
the last year
um so this thing comes up on Instagram
and I'm watching it
and I started sobbing
crying at a like I couldn't stop and
here's what was magic I look up and I
was waiting for Josephine to get out of
the shower and she has one of these uh
wraparound towels with like a hoodie on
it and so she wraps herself real tight
when she gets out of the shower and it's
just her face poking out
and
I didn't know she'd come into the room
and she had just materialized into the
room and was just looking across the
room at me and I am sobbing looking at
this phone I look up and see her we make
eye contact and she said are you okay
Daddy and I said yeah yeah I'm okay go
get dressed go get dressed and she goes
to get dressed and she comes back and I
sat down and I just told her
there is this woman and her husband was
being really mean and was trying to hurt
her and her baby and her eyes got really
big and I told her in an age-appropriate
way and I said and daddy
um and his friends helped this lady and
it just made me sad thinking about how
scared she was and made me so grateful
that um there's people there to take
care of her so I talked to her and she
just stood there for a count of like
three or four seconds said nothing I'm
sitting in a chair and she's just this
little tiny little seven-year-old girl
and then she just leaned in and gave me
the biggest hug of my life and she said
nothing she just squeezed me so tight
and I thought to myself of all the
things all the moments she's broken my
heart last five years
we're gonna be all right we're gonna
there is something about the hug of your
little daughter
um but I tell I tell everybody to tell
you that that this I'm dealing with
these new things called feelings and I'm
still working about how they dismantify
this work through my body and more
importantly in real time in my house
one of the greatest gifts I can give my
kid is to show them that their old man
has some emotion if their Old Man shows
up in hard situations and it scares him
to death and he cries and he says yeah I
was really nervous and I was really
scared and I didn't know what to do or I
didn't know what to do and it still made
me scared and it's okay just to be quiet
and accept a hug from a five-year-old
little girl seven-year-old little girl
from my wife from my son
all of The Human Experience is okay and
his parents if we can share that with
our kids it is Magic for changing that
family tree
It's Magic It's Magic don't hide from
your kids don't hide from your kids all
right let's go out to Wisconsin and talk
to Come On Eileen what's up Eileen how
we doing hi how how are you partying how
are you I'm actually taking my lunch but
um that's so funny that you said Come On
Eileen you're uh
um when I was a kid now you got to
remember my name rhymes with like a
terrible lunch meat right so
um I was John baloney and we had a
friend like in our little gang named
Eileen and we used to call her I leaned
over and we used to say is your friend
Ben coming over and I always thought
that was hilarious I leaned over and
bend over so um same team so what's up
dude
hi
um so I like wrote I know I know I know
so I wrote down my question because I
knew that I was just gonna like go
rambling on so my question is go for it
um I'm afraid so okay I'm afraid my
daughters will follow my footsteps and
become a teen mom like I was and I know
you often say like you know there you
have an alarm system well my alarms are
like blaring right now
um I have a 14 and 13 year old right now
but
um I have five I have five kids four of
them girls
yes wow okay I know I know
um that's a lot in that house
yeah yeah a lot and then uh my boy
doesn't have any say pretty much but are
you married
um I just got divorced okay all right
yeah okay but
um yeah my alarms are like you know just
blaring and I've become very controlling
um with my older ones I have more
patience with the younger ones but with
my 14 and 13 year olds I am so
controlling to the point that the other
day my daughter
um she said mom you're literally making
me feel like I'm a up and I'm like
that's not my intention and
um I often and I'm gonna get emotional
because yeah all right it's all right go
for it
I feel like
I'm still controlling because I want
I don't want this life that I mean I I
think I have a good life now you know
but I don't want them to go through the
struggles that I did
um and I often my anxiety kicks in and I
often portray that as anger when I'm
talking to them when I'm trying to walk
them through a life situation or
um
so I I like I play this in my head like
maybe if my parents just you know
told me hey just keep playing sports or
you know like do this club in high
school or something you know and so I've
been doing that with my girls that's not
it
tell me about your um tell me about your
divorce
um so
so
um I met him when I was uh
19. and that yeah I was 19 but my three
my three older kiddos they're from my
high school not so sweetheart I like to
say okay
um and uh I spent pretty much all my 20s
um in this relationship and it's funny
how like how old reunion your first kid
I was 16. 16. okay
16 and I had my so 16 17 and 19. okay
and that's for the high school boyfriend
yeah okay all right and so is that dude
still in the picture
um no he never really was
um until after my son was born you know
I just I I had this picture like I want
a family I want this to work out but he
was always cheating on me and
um so I you know I finished high school
did some college and
um you know now I'm here but then I met
you know my ex my ex-husband um
and uh we ended up getting married and
we had two more kids
um and he pretty much is Raising he's
raising all the kiddos
um I think we have a better relationship
now than we did as we were married
um why is that
um
he was very jealous I'm like a very
only I talked to everybody I just you
know I I'm a happy person and he was
he he had a lot of trauma okay
okay we eat a lot of trauma and um he
couldn't understand how
you know he could be loved when he just
grew up in a house where there was no
love at all
um and I try to love him and can you
understand that
yeah I understand it now no no no no can
you understand being loved
to be honest okay them no I don't
think you can I don't think you can
so let me let me
like as I'm listening to you talk yes
you've got teenage girls they are
entering into the season when you
discovered your sexuality guys started
giving you attention and that whole
thing went sideways you had a baby at
16. that's a that's a that's a huge uh I
don't know if it's called traumatizing
but it's a it's a kid having a kid right
that's a huge thing
yeah and were your parents involved at
all
[Music]
my mom and they both came from really
big families where my grandma also had
her kid at like 15 you know sure
um it wasn't a weird you weren't a
terrible human kind of thing
right right right you know okay so
um so it just was what it was but but
here's what I want to say like
um
it's right for your body to be trying to
get your attention right it went through
a lot
16 years old is tough that's really hard
even with your it's a full support of
your family that's hard and then another
one is 17.
I'm in my 40s and I have two kids and I
don't know what day it is
when I was 17 17
God Almighty and then you had a third
like so
and then you the dad never shows up
and he's just a bum an absolute bum
and you have these visions and these
dreams of what love is going to look
like and what family is going to look
like and not only that but you have the
first generation pressure of you're
gonna make it you're going to do all
these things that we didn't get to do
that's why we're here right and you have
all this pressure all this stuff and
then you find somebody that says I do
and he's got his own trauma passed and
he's trying to raise five kids and you
all are trying to raise five kids
what it sounds like to me is you've got
a body that has been screaming at you
for years that honey we are not safe
we're not safe we're not connected we
are one or two decisions away from not
having food on the table
and first first baby daddy like
he didn't want to be around and now this
guy doesn't want to be around like
your body's trying to get your attention
and so yeah we gotta deal with the high
school kids I mean we got to deal with
that that's that's gonna come and I've
got some some thoughts about that
the greatest gift you can give your
daughters
is for you
to break what I would say is a
generational curse
and that is I'm gonna take care of Mom
and make sure Mom is well and Mom is
whole
I promise you with all my heart
your parents telling you to go play
softball or to be on the track team
would not have made you feel more loved
it wouldn't have
and you know that too right
yeah
and so how long how long have you been
divorced
um
well we've been separate
every two years and divorced for one
so are the girls in the boy are they
going back and forth how they were how
y'all working that out
the girls don't usually go over there
anymore
um because they rather hang out with
their friends
um there's times where they do go hang
out with you know they call him dad
um but the three younger ones they're
there Tuesdays and like Wednesdays
overnight
um and then I get them the rest of the
week and you know because I I deliver my
also my schedule it's kind of wonky
um
but uh and you know I have been
um like you said taking care of Mom so I
have been
um you know feeding a therapist and my
me and my two older girls actually see
the same therapist we I feel like
there's some trauma there maybe like me
growing up because you said you know a
kid raising a kid yeah yeah it's just
gonna be hard no matter what yeah yeah
how's that going
um it's going really good um I actually
saw her yesterday
um and she she said that my oldest
um said so she said your oldest can come
back whenever she feels like she wants
to because I think she's she's done
she's been doing great
um so whenever that pops up you know
I'll send it back but an important part
about the counseling is
it gives you tools
here's what I think I think between you
especially your tools and we you and I
could talk for probably six hours on all
the all the pieces to this but let's
focus on on the two uh oldest girls
because that's that's the main reason
why I call
um
what those girls need more than anything
is a direct line connection with their
mom
and this sounds like some big like
spectacles some big fireworks show
that's not how this works
this is
week after week you've heard me say this
if you listen to show ever about
um I think it was a year maybe two years
ago I started having just a weekly
breakfast with my son this year my
daughter is in second grade and I'm
gonna add her so twice a week that's a
big commitment for us financially it's a
big commitment for us time wise
especially time
um but once a week I go to lunch with my
I mean I go to breakfast with my son and
I don't miss
ever unless I'm out of town if I'm out
of town I gotta make it up and I'm gonna
add my daughter too and here's what it
is it is
lame conversation after
we play questions for humans we talk
about books that we're reading my son
and I are gonna get a little more
intentional my daughter's just gonna be
building relationships and in those
moments over the course of one year two
years I've been able to say hey I made
this mistake in Middle School
and here's what it cost me
here's what it did
and you're going to be able to say hey
the single greatest decision I ever made
in my life was having you
and at 16 it was really really hard
but what your girls need more than
um somebody micromanaging every breath
and every thought
is a mom that they know and they trust
and they love is that fair
yeah and there's probably some things
you have never told them there's
probably some things that they're not
old enough to know they're only 13 14.
and you can tell her tell these girls
when you're 18 when you're 21 there's
some stuff about Mom's life I'm gonna
tell you
I'm gonna tell you about the hard stuff
not because I want you to feel sorry for
me but because y'all are young women in
this crazy crazy world and I want you
all to walk into the world with with
eyes wide open
and also I tell you all that to tell you
this
restriction is also super important for
14 and 13 year olds
can I tell you what I mean by that
you're gonna think I'm insane
a 14 year old girl has zero none no
business having a smartphone zero
a 14 year old girl has no business going
on dates none zero
too young they're a child
okay 14 year olds should be allowed to
go to parties where there's guys and
girls there but there's got to be adults
there and parents it's their job to call
and make sure those adults there and
make sure there are
um there are people with the same values
that we have
and I've had hard conversations with my
kids I'm sorry this is adults between
adults but you can't go to this and I
know it's disappointing I know it's
heartbreaking
but I have one job
and so there is these move right which
is you just need to connect and let them
go let them go be them bull crap and
there's also the shut them down you
treat them like robots and that's
bullcrap too what I'm telling you Ellen
is you got to do both you got to listen
to those alarms and know they're your
alarms not everybody's right and if you
continue
um working on your own anxiety and what
does that mean I'm gonna send you my
book my brand new book uh building a
non-anxious life for free it's been my
gift to you okay it's not even out in
the world yet I'm gonna send it to you
okay but there's some there's a path to
take so that your alarms settle settle
down enough
so that you can then interact with the
world and identify real threats real
challenges that come up and it's not
just ringing off the hook all the time
24 7 365. uh I'm gonna tell you
something crazy last night
I just went up to my bed and I went to
sleep my wife has the flu so I'm
sleeping upstairs I just went to bed no
drugs I just turned the light off and
went to sleep can you imagine that
yeah you know
this morning I had some coffee I had to
be up here super super early for some
media I left my house at 5 15.
I just asked a cup of coffee
I'm kind of tired it was a great day can
you imagine that
I am like that's what I want for you so
bad
but I can't want it more than you want
it do you want it that bad
yeah I've actually been um working on
that honestly I'm so proud of you
and uh I actually so
um for the past two months I've made
complete changes because
um I I trained you Jitsu and with my
work schedule it's been really just I
haven't been able to make the evening
classes like I want to so I started
waking up and going to the morning
classes before work and
um I just started my meal plan again and
everything and I've been feeling great
and so like well now you know what else
do I do and I want to ask I've asked my
girls like come train with me you know
and they have this thing where they just
don't want to right now so I'm gonna say
something that's kind of controversial
okay
okay there are 13 and 14.
they have a um they get they get a vote
but not the final one
okay so you can tell them you don't have
to train but you're coming to the gym
with me
are y'all gonna sit over there in the
chair but you're coming to the gym
you're not just gonna sit here my mom
goes and trains and if nothing else if
nothing else they get to watch their mom
be an absolute gangster
training early in the morning
and you get to offer it and offer it and
offer you guys want to get on Match you
want to get on the match you wanna train
I'm all in
and then after six months if they don't
want to then they get to choose
something my rule with my kids is you
got to do something you can't just sit
at home and go because even the best
kids in the world are still 13 and 14
year olds and they can't compete with
the screens and the video games and the
smartphone they can't compete with all
that crap and so it's up to the parents
to say you gotta get out of the house
you got to go do one thing
and I know I also talk about the
insanity of like travel Sports and all
the lunacy like let's go they're not
semi-professional athletes at seven or
at 14 right so I get that too there's a
happy medium
but in many ways they don't get a vote
I mean they can say like I don't want to
do Jiu Jitsu that's fine but we're gonna
go to the gym
so you can you can participate are you
gonna sit there in that chair you're not
gonna sit there on your phone either by
the way you can take a book if you'd
like you can read but that's it that's
it that's gonna happen this way and
expect pushback expect them to be 14 and
13 year olds like you and I both were
expect them to roll their eyes and be
like oh Mom's the worst you're not
you're not
the the grand picture here is this
let them know who their mom is let them
know begin to get a glimpse slowly open
the door of the next few years as to the
things mom has experienced
and continue to hold the line continue
to be a parent that has boundaries and
restrictions and takes care of their
children which is what 13 and 14 year
olds are
and if the smartphone thing isn't out of
the out of the gate already if the just
complete access to every movie channel
ever made isn't already out of the barn
take it back
take it back you're the parent
you're the parent it's both in as we
navigate this thing and if you see your
daughter getting too close to somebody
cut it off
cut it off call it out
put your daughter in safe positions okay
it's both and it's all of it this is
hard and this is messy but here's the
big the biggest of all all the pictures
here here's the biggest meta takeaway
the anxiety alarms are yours not theirs
you said something really important at
the beginning of the call that your
anxiety comes out like anger towards
them don't take the bricks out of your
backpack and hit your kids with them and
I know you don't want to
that means the work that has to be done
is work on you
continue to to see a counselor continue
to work on those things like your
physical body your nutrition continue to
do those things continue to write down
your thoughts and work hard to change
those automated things I'm gonna send
you this book work through these six
daily choices get out of debt stop owing
people money create a life where you are
free
or you're free
and then when your 14 year old comes
wandering into the room rolling her eyes
out of the back of her head you can kind
of smile
you're not gonna make me mad you're 14
and no you're not going to this party
there's not going to be any adults and
no you're not gonna have a smartphone
because I'm I love you too much no fill
in the blank that's my job but
I'm gonna take you out let's go grab
three friends we're going to the movies
and you're gonna have capacity and space
it's Freedom it's peace and this my
sister
changing your family tree hang on the
line we'll be right back
all right let's go out to Michigan to
Grand Rapids and talk to the great and
wonderful Carrie what's up Carrie
and thank you so much for taking my call
of course how are you this morning I I
could not be better doing great doing
great so what's up
well
um so I have a situation my my husband
is suffering from anxiety and depression
and it's been affecting me and our
five-year-old son
um he really refuses to talk about it
um he just kind of brushes off
suggestions to get outside help
and
um I just don't know how to support him
I don't know what I can do to help
but it's gotten to the point where you
know I just I don't want to live this
way any longer especially if he's
kind of shutting everything down and not
wanting to address it
my
um
my heart's broken because my wife could
have been the one that made this call
I've been there on the other side of
this thing and so I get it
I also get you have to take care of
yourself
and you have to take care of that little
one
and it can feel like
um one thing I didn't get especially
initially
is that there's a lot of you looking in
the mirror saying what is it about me
that isn't good enough for him to go get
the help he needs what is it about our
kid
that isn't a big enough deal that he's
gonna go get the help he needs
exactly yeah those those questions will
drag you underwater right
yeah well I have a little bit of
background okay on this I think that it
started I'm not sure but
um so less than a month of us uh dating
uh we've actually we've been together
about 18 years and married for 11.
um less than one month into US dating
his mom was murdered overseas wow and he
did not take any time off work he stayed
as busy as he could he worked overtime
tried to find projects to do around the
house
we have reason to believe that his
brother had something to do with that so
of course you know he's kind of lost
that relationship too
um but now he's I believe that he's
still using being busy as a coping
mechanism
and we feel like we're in his way
um
constantly just on the go on the go on
the go
yes
you may have heard me say my buddy uh
Ian Simpkins
um
gave me a great line one time said that
if if busyness is your drug then rest
will feel like stress yes that
he kicks in
weekends are very hard for us
because it throws us off for a normal
routine
um it feels like you're married to uh my
wife described it she said it was like
being married to a taser
yes it was just electric and if I said
anything
she's like I obviously I've never hit my
wife I didn't scream I wasn't loud or
anything but she said if I said
something it just came back so electric
that I just
found it easier to say nothing it's just
safer to say nothing
um and then he feels that disconnection
which makes him go to the only thing he
only drug he knows which is work more
which then pulls him further away into
just getting this this cycle so let me
let me tell you this I'm gonna tell you
exactly what helped in my life okay I'm
gonna give you the Playbook that that
ultimately
pulled me out of this mess and saved my
life and
um may not work for everybody my life
isn't everybody's life
um but it's the best road map I got okay
okay number one I want to avoid the Trap
of saying everybody Grieves in the same
way and I really fell into this early on
okay I would tell old grizzled ranchers
you need to spend some time crying and
that was wrong they didn't
their bodies metabolized trauma
differently than mine did it just did
and so there's not a right or wrong way
for this to look and so I want to look
move the the way that he quote unquote
should be grieving his mom the way he
should have grieved his mom I want to
move all that to the side
the second thing I want to move to the
side is any sort of clinical Diagnostics
has he ever gone to a psychologist or
medical doctor and been diagnosed as
anxious and and with some sort of
depressive disorder some type of anxiety
disorder
no okay I want to move all Diagnostics
off to the side
okay let's move them over there let's
stop using the words anxiety stop using
the words depression those are clinical
terms that's like saying you got the flu
or you've got some sort of infection and
you need to get antibiotics I'm not
taking antibiotics you really don't know
so let's move those things over to the
side
I want you to
so we got those over the side so here's
what you can do okay number one this is
gonna sound nuts and I know you're going
to think all right idiot I've already
tried this
but this isn't a one and done thing I'm
talking about this as an ethos okay as a
way of being in your body's alarms are
going to ring off the hook
the only time I would tell you don't do
this is if he is abusive either verbally
or physically okay is he either of those
two things
no okay cool I want you to create a
posture of leaning towards him not away
okay here's what that looks like when he
walks in the door everything in your
body says get out of the room
I want you to go towards him when
um he's sitting down at the table kind
of like that my wife called it the
Sunday afternoon bear there's just a
bear in the living room and we just know
to avoid it
I want you to go sit by him
real close
make him tell you to move
because I'm telling you he probably
won't
if he does now you have an Avenue we got
to deal with some bigger issues here
okay
and okay so we're gonna lean in instead
of pulling away number two I want you to
start calling a spade a spade what do I
mean by that
honey you cannot disappear when I bring
our son into the house
that's different than your anxieties
driving us crazy
I want you to be very specific about the
things he is doing in the house that is
causing you and your son and your home
to not be whole
because when you take a doer when you
take somebody who's obsessed with whose
drug is being busy
and you say I need these specific things
at first those become tasks to check off
and what he'll find is
my wife leans in a lot closer when I'm
helping around the house
and when I'm quiet
and when I'm exhaling in his body his
nervous system will begin to respond
before his head does his head will be
like oh it's so annoying I gotta do the
dishes on top of everything else I'm
doing
yeah body will relax
okay here's number three
okay I did not know this had happened
but my buddy I we had my son Hank I
think he was two
um maybe he was 18 months old
one of my best friends on the planet
Todd he had a little boy and him he
called and he's like hey me and my wife
are coming to bring our kid over he
lived about three hours away I'd moved
away after college and um we're gonna
bring our little boy over so our boys
can meet and you can meet my son and I
want to meet your son all that I was
like that sounds great
and when he came over I spent a couple
hours with him talking about everything
about this and about this and what about
this and the economy is going to do this
my house was falling apart here and all
this I went all all in
he was my friend and I vomited all over
him and he walked around the house with
me looked at all the problems and I'll
never forget this we were out on my
driveway
and he looked at it and you got to
picture this I'm a wild haired just
loudmouth guy and I've calmed
down a lot over the last decade I was a
mess and he is this he's had the same
haircut since he was zero years old
um he tucks his shirt in to go to bed I
think
um he's just like a straight lady he's a
banker he's just as straight as could be
okay
um everything's lined up
and
he had his hands in his pockets and he
listened to me and listened to me and
then he finally looked at me and said
hey
your house is good
this conversation is over we're not
having it anymore
and you need to go get yourself checked
out
and that was the first time in my life
when he left
I thought the first time I thought it
may be me
because I trusted that guy
and I came to find out later my wife had
called him and said I'm really worried
about John and I don't know what to do
and he had said I'll come down and talk
to him and he brought his family I'm
getting all choked up just thinking
about it now
he took a day off of work and drove down
to see me
and so it may be that you reach out to a
friend of his one or two of his buddies
who love him
and she's since done that again and it
was really important
in fact when I was writing this last
book she called two of my she called
Todd and another one of my friends John
and they flew down to see me here in
Nashville
and after that I went and checked myself
into a hotel then after that I went and
checked myself I went and got with a
trauma counselor and started some real
healing it was really important but it
started with my wife saying okay he
listens to these men in his life he
needs to reach I'm going to reach out to
them and it wasn't a violation of my
trust it was her saying I love you and
this guy I need some oxygen and those
guys have oxygen from my husband
and so number three is reach out to
somebody that might be able to get
through it to him in a way that you
can't
okay okay
but I want to throw away the um the
clinical language be very clear and
specific and ultimately the conversation
with my wife that changed my life was in
our backyard in a couple of folding
chairs it wasn't any Grand thing
and I said I feel like you're creating a
life without me and she said I have to
because you're not okay
that's exactly what has been happening
with us okay
um we there's so many things that I have
done by myself with my son I've I've had
to take him out as a home
um and just do things on our own we've
have you told your husband that
yes and he knows okay
um
we've gone to a holiday you know dinners
at relative's house and he stayed at
home we've you know we've gone to have
you said the words to your husband in a
private conversation
I don't want to do my life alone anymore
I want you by my side
um
okay not not exactly in those words
here's the deal Carrie you have to be
that specific and here's what I know
here's why I think you're crying why
it's terrifying because he might say no
he might say I'm not doing it
but if you're like hey are you going to
this dinner hey do you want to come play
soccer with us hey you want to go out to
the to the market with us he's always
going to say no that anxiety is too
strong the depression's too strong
whatever's going on in his heart and
mind is too strong
but if the woman he loves and the mother
of his son sits down in front of him and
says I'm tired of doing my life by
myself I need you by my side
whatever it takes for you to get well
I'm all in but I'm not doing my life by
myself anymore or I'm going to do it all
by myself
you don't want it to come to that I know
Carrie but you're there
and here's what happens inside this
house
you start creating your own life he
knows it his body feels it and he
doesn't know what to do and so what does
he do he just does his drugs which is
work more and work more which makes you
have to do more of your life and you
just all of a sudden you wake up and
you're five years later and you're
sitting on the couch next to him and
you're six inches apart but you're six
thousand miles away from each other
yeah right yes I felt that before I know
I know I know
here's the deal you've heard me say this
on the show this is about turning all
the lights on turning the music off
and saying the life we are co-creating
together ends today
will you build something new with me
and you have to be ready for him to say
no I won't
and hopefully that's vulnerability right
When You're vulnerable like it's a cool
buzzword but you can get hurt when
you're vulnerable
but I want to tell you you're getting
hurt now
you're getting hurt now you're slowly
drowning
that's exactly what it feels like and I
feel like it's not fair it's more fun
it's not gonna absorb absorbs everything
and
Terry it's not fair to you either it's
not fair to your husband it's not fair
to anybody
yeah okay don't just do it for your son
do it for your husband do it for you do
it for this thing called marriage this
thing y'all are building together
I strongly recommend you don't do this
on the back end of a fight tell them
oh and have a long conversation
um I always tell people it kind of
turned into a joke around here like a
meme around here but I always tell
people to go to breakfast because it's
early in the morning and it's sunshine
you know outside sometimes
um and once people get to like nine
o'clock there's no more productive
conversations happening you can have a
bunch of deep philosophical mumbo-jumbo
at two in the morning but good deep
conversations happen when everyone's
brain is clear and so I recommend get a
babysitter for your son and take your
husband out and say I'm taking you out
um
and we have to talk about some big
picture stuff
okay
um stay on the line here I'm gonna send
you a copy of I'm gonna send you both
books one is own your past change your
future and that is about okay we're in
Ash what do we do now
how do we get here and then what do we
do now and then my newest book Building
A non-anxious Life That's a book you and
your husband can read together about
building a completely new life
and there's some choices y'all can make
every day every week every month about
building something completely new
it will involve him getting the help he
needs but I want to tell you someone
who's been there it took me
a year with a guy named Randy and a guy
named Slade two guys that kept showing
up for me one guy in the weight room
then we'd go to lunch it took me that
long and it took me to get a new job
and then it took me getting some new
friends into some confrontations before
I ever went and saw a counselor I didn't
just race right into it I didn't I
didn't have that kind of Courage I
didn't even know the words to say
and then I got around some more friends
and some more it was a long long walk
but I got healthier and healthier and
healthier as I went and then I had some
big blow ups almost blew my marriage up
kept going kept going kept going
okay so this isn't just a one and done
deal this is a journey y'all are heading
on your husband's been through hell and
back and you've been by his side every
time
it's time for you to stop getting
dragged behind the boat though
take ownership of your life of your son
of your home turn the lights on
stop the music
and let him know the life we have
co-created up until now this one's over
I want to build something new
something where we're doing this
together
I hope with everything I have that
you'll join me
I want to do this with you
carry call anytime I'll be with you
every step of the way call anytime let
us know how that conversation goes we'll
be rooting for you and if he wants to
call me I'd love to talk to him love to
talk to him we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
get out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we're back and go figure
Kelly's out today so there's no like
mustache rock or marble Reds
um it was gonna be either Taylor Swift
or Paramore and today we went with
Paramore hey Jenna do you see that um uh
do you see that thing in Seattle oh the
earthquake
on the Richter Scale Rachel Cruz was
there I know and half of that thing was
her screaming her head exactly and had
the other half would have been me had I
been there but I could have been it's
kind of like not cool you run her life
you produce her show and she chose her
husband over you that's so ridiculous no
I get it there's always the Euro plug of
the tour if you go to Europe to see that
would be amazing if you did that that'd
be pretty cool actually all right
today's uh song of the day is by the
great Paramore this song's called Last
Hope and it goes like this I didn't even
know myself at all I thought I'd be
happy by now and the more I try to push
it I realize I gotta let go of control
gotta let it happen
just a spark but it's enough to keep me
going when it's dark out no one's around
it keeps glowing every night I try my
best to dream tomorrow makes it better
and then I wake up to the cold reality
and not a thing has changed
but it will happen gotta let it happen
open your hands up jump
thank y'all for being with us see you
soon